Breaking the fourth wall is one of the most unique and thematic tools that a filmmaker has
can use. Most cinematic techniques are used to draw us into the story
and to forget that we are watching a movie. The breaking of the fourth wall does the opposite. It remembers
us that we are a viewer watching what is happening on the screen.
The technology can contribute to
visual telling the story in different ways, depending on how it is used.
To truly understand the power of the fourth wall fracture, we must look at its origin,
in the theatre.
An appropriate definition for breaking the fourth wall
is' ​​a dramatic technique in a fiction story where the characters show that they are aware
of their existence in the story.
This technique goes as far back as ancient Greece, continued into Shakespeare's time and further into postmodern theater, particularly in musicals.
The term originated with the emergence of the 'box decor' that became popular in the early 19th century. Decors
were made with three walls, with the fourth imaginary wall located between the stage and
the public. So when a character acknowledged the existence of the public,
then the fourth wall was broken.
The technique has been used since the stupid era,
and Charlie Chapin played a lot with technology in his own films.
With the advent of sound and the popularity of the musical genre, fourth-wall breaks were
more ordinary and actively contributed to the screening of the film. In the next 70 years,
fourth-wall breaks would find their way into different film genres with different results.
This technique is best known in comedy,
and the comedy is known for possessing some of the most unforgettable punch lines in film history.
There is something very special and comical about remembering that
we are in the middle of a movie. No matter how often I watch a movie breaking the fourth wall,
the joke can still surprise me.
The joke must leave the movie to deliver the punch line, and no other joke can do that.
Every other joke is caught in the imaginary world of the story. To step out of that world,
is what makes the fourth wall fracture so fun and creative.
This does not mean that breaking the fourth wall automatically makes you a comedy genius.
The design and delivery of a fourth wall fracture must be surprising in some way,
otherwise the joke will not come across.
You can't talk about breaking the fourth wall without the mention of Mel Brooks.
He broke the fourth wall in the most extreme ways.
His films even go so far that the characters view themselves in the film.
While his films are funny because of their absurdity,
there is certainly some logic in it.
I love the way Blazing Saddles uses the fourth wall to ridicule the 'Western' genre.
It shows very well how unrealistic the Hollywood films were in their portrayal of life in the West.
In reality, Western films were nothing but actors in a studio, playing in fake towns,
who eventually drove home with their car. Blazing Saddles is a not so subtle one
reminder that film also has its own limitations in imagining reality.
Mel Brooks made a statement by pointing out the lack of reality in the Western film.
Western films from the 40s, 50s and 60s completely ignored racism, xenophobia and other ugly sides of the West,
and Blazing Saddles breaks the fourth wall in an extreme way, to remind us
that we are watching a dramatized film, not reality.
What may make the breaking of the fourth wall so impressive is that it depends on the context,
the act of recognizing the public is actually pushing us more into the film,
instead of pulling us out.
There is something intimate about the way a character speaks directly to us. In Road to Morocco, Bing Crosby and Bob Hope make light-hearted jokes
straight to the public, and remind us that their adventure will eventually end well.
By the relaxing and inviting breaking of the fourth wall, we know that this is a film that is itself
Don't take it too seriously, and offer light-hearted, conservative entertainment. The
breaking the fourth wall can be a way to invite us into the story, and this technique is certain
an indication of a more mild and good-natured film.
A fourth wall break can let us be intimate with a character, but also the story. There is nothing
stronger than showing the hidden motifs than by the character
right to let us look and tell them.
It is a great way to show what is happening in the head
of a character, and is comparable to an 'aside' in the theater. Frank Underwood who speaks directly to us,
is the basis for so much energy in House of Cards.
I love the scenes where he says something to one character
and then looks at us and tells us what he really wants.
The last important effect of the fourth wall fracture is it
"make it unpleasant." There is nothing worse than feeling safe while watching a movie
until the villain suddenly looks you in the eye.
Jakkes.
Comedy, satire, intimacy and fear can all succeed with just one glance into the camera.
So don't underestimate the potential of a fourth wall fracture, and thank you for looking